Perris private text Sam Megan Markel's
father revealed as the Duchess case
against the mell on Sunday heats up
there really was no other option to
Thomas Marvel which the newspaper
published now this case is going to go
ahead on Friday it is going to be
conducted via videolink
what's more Megan's UK lawyers have
released court documents which reveal
shocking new details about her
relationship with her estranged father
Thomas Merkel who has said he tried to
reach out prior to Megan and Harry's May
2018 wedding from Megan and Harry
clearly reaching out to Thomas at this
time once ex dated May 14th 2018 it
reads quote Tom it's Harry and I'm going
to call you right now please pick up
thank you according to court dockets for
the couple's wedding around the time
when Thomas was accused of working with
the paparazzi and a second text that
same day
Harry writes in part quote if you love
Meg and wants to make it right please
call me meg and I are not angry we just
need to speak with you thanks according
to the docs
Harry texts a third time on the
fourteenth writing quote Oh
any speaking to the press will backfire
trust me Tom only we can help you as we
have been trying from day one according
to the newly filed court documents
Megan first learned of her father's
health setback from TMZ's coverage the
documents also claim that the Duchess
continued reaching out to her father in
days leading up to her wedding
expressing concern about his quote
health and safety I'll not be bullied
and to enter into playing a game that's
they kill my mother
what's more Harry and Megan just
announced they're cutting ties with four
British tabloids
well the world is engaged in a fight
against Kovac 19 Megan and Harry are
engaged in a fight against the British
press Megan and Harry have made it very
clear that they feel coverage in these
titles which include the Sun the mirror
the Daily Mail and the Daily Express has
been unfair untrue and inaccurate and as
a result of that they have said they
will not be engaging on any level with
these publications but some are calling
their decision censorship there has as
you might expect being quite a backlash
you know we've seen President Trump
refused to engage with certain media
outlets now we're seeing the sixes
really take similar measures some people
see that as censorship for the sixes
it's a matter of choice I always protect
my family and now I have a family to
protect
[Music]